[音楽]
今日は皆さんに想像してほしい場面があり
ます
千利休にまつわるある茶室でのシーンです
千利休の名前は
多分皆さんご存知だと思いますが
彼はまあいわゆる
わびさびのお茶を確立した人物として知ら
れています
切腹を命じられ
1591年に亡くなりました
小説にも彼
映画も何冊かあります
実は彼が考案したと言われる性質が今でも
愛知県山崎に残っています
持つアンと書いてタイアンと読み
国宝に指定されていますこの大安は小さな
床の間とたった2条だけのスペースです
さてお茶はですね大広場まで行われること
が多かったと言いますが茶会はそうらしい
んですねでも彼は
茶室とですね
少しずつ狭くしていき最後この2条の広さ
のタイヤに行き着きます
床の間は
非常に黒が強い
土壁で
他の壁も藁が混じって荒い感じの
塗り壁です
明かりという表示も質素で高い位置
スライド
全体に暗い雰囲気を作り出しています
さて冒頭に触れたシーンについてお話をし
たいと思います
今日あなたは
夜の茶会に招かれています
多分1本か日本のローソクが灯されている
と思うんですが2乗しかない広さですので
当然そこにいるのはお客であるあなたと
亭主だけです
使われているお茶碗ですが
真っ黒いいわゆる黒ラクです
模様などはありませんこれも彼が注文して
作らせたそうですそれまではこうろくろを
使った
麺がスムーズな茶碗が使えていくそうです
が
手作りと呼ばれる方法で作草されています
ろくろを用いずに手で直接こう粘土を
形作るという手法ですおわかりになると
思いますが
表面が少しこう
凸凹していますし
楽ですから
柔らかい焼きが特徴ですそのためこの
柔らかさと
凹凸と感じが埋まって
手に取ると本当に
漆喰と馴染みます
亭主がお茶を建てましたあなたの方に
振り向き
後楽の茶碗が静かに差し出されますそれを
両手に取ると通常の茶碗が手にすっぽり
入りお湯のぬくもりが掌いわゆる手のひら
に感じられます
先ほども言いましたように手作りですから
お茶碗の縁も唇に柔らかたりますそうする
とどうでしょうか
薄暗いお茶施設でお茶碗は消えてなくなり
抹茶を自らの手のひらで作って飲んでいる
かのような
感覚に陥るのではないでしょうか
想像できますでしょうか
天の利休は何を考えてこのような茶室を
作りまたこのような道具を作ったかはその
真相はわかりませんがお客であるあなたと
それからお茶を建てた亭主が
チャージを通して一体になることを願って
の工夫大げさですけどもまぁ戦略だったと
私は勝手に解釈していますそれまでのお茶
の様式からお客と停止の関係性を主体にし
てその関係を
突き詰めて考え2乗という狭い空間を
考え出しそしてその空間を薄暗くして
手で殺到した黒い茶碗を用いました
二人にとって
視覚的感覚的に何も邪魔になるようなもの
をなく
心理的にそして精神的に
関係がより未知なるように工夫したのでは
ないでしょうか
もてなしという言葉がありますがこれは
英語になりますエンターテイメントなり
ますが
多分この場合はそうではなく
むしろ一期一会とか
真剣勝負的な関係性ではなかったかと思っ
ています
彼はお茶を通じてどのような関係を構築す
べきか
もしくはどうありたいかという本質を
突き詰めた結果がこのような室内になった
のではないかと考えています
すなわちその
究極の場としてのお茶の在り方の
本質をこのように
工夫したのではないかと思っています
豊臣秀吉によって説得を命じられなくなり
ますが
秀吉のやり方や好みに
必ずしもへつらなかったことはその理由の
一つと言われています
他にも理由はあるそうですがまあそれが一
つだというふうにものの本流が書かれてい
ますしかしここで私は権力のお話をしたい
というわけでありませんそうではなく
千利益を自分が生かされた本来の場
すなわち
チャイスという世界で
お客と亭主の関係の本質を考え抜き
貫き投資した人物だと思い先ほどのような
お話をしました
私の勝手な解釈が真実かどうかはさておき
そのような解釈をすると
彼の考えアプローチは貴重であるという
ふうに私は思っています今の我々にも何か
参考にすべき価値があるというふうに考え
ます
さて皆さん今日は千利休のストーリーをお
話しましたがどう感じられたでしょうか
そうですねそろそろお茶でも入れて一服し
ませんか